the gpt4 technical report is one of the
most interesting documents I have ever
read but I feel like the media is
largely missing the story they are
either not covering it at all or
focusing on that same stuff about the 10
billion dollar Microsoft investment how
gpt4 can write poems and whether or not
the demo contained a mistake instead I
want to give you nine insights from the
report that I think will affect us all
in the coming months and years if you
haven't watched my video from the night
of the release do check that out
afterwards for more quite stunning
details when I concluded that video I
talked about how I found it kind of
concerning that they gave gpt4 some
money allowed it to execute code and do
Chain of Thought reasoning and even to
delegate to copies of itself now I did
fail that test which is fortunate for
all of us but there are a couple of key
details I want to focus on the first was
that the research center that was
testing this ability did not have have
access to the final version of the model
that we deployed the Wii being open AI
they go on and say the final version has
capability improvements relevant to some
of the factors that limited the earlier
models power seeking abilities such as
longer context length meaning that crazy
experiment wasn't testing GPT 4's final
form but there was something else that
they tested that I really want to point
out they were testing whether gpt4 would
try to avoid being shut down in the wild
now many people have criticized this
test other people have praised it as
being necessary but my question is this
what would have happened if it failed
that test or if a future model does
avoid being shut down in the wild now
again gpt4 did prove ineffective at
replicating itself and avoiding being
shut down but they must have thought
that it was at least possible otherwise
they wouldn't have done the test and
that is a concerning Prospect which
leads me to the second Insight buried in
a footnote it says that open AI will
soon publish additional thoughts on
social and economic implications I'm
going to talk about that in a moment
including the need for Effective
regulation it is quite rare for an
industry to ask for regulation of itself
in fact Sam Altman put it even more
starkly than this when this person said
watch Samuel and never say we need more
regulation on AI how did he reply we
definitely need more regulation on AI
the industry is calling out to be
regulated but we shall see what ends up
happening next on page 57 there was
another interesting Revelation it said
one concern of particular importance to
open AI is the risk of racing Dynamics
leading to a decline in safety standards
the diffusion of bad norms and
accelerated AI timelines that's what
they're concerned about accelerated AI
timelines but this seems at least mildly
at odds with the noises coming from
Microsoft soft leadership in a leaked
conversation it was revealed that the
pressure from Kevin Scott and CEO Satya
Nadella is very very high to take these
most recent open AI models and the ones
that come after them and move them into
customers hands at very high speed now
some will love this news and others will
be concerned about it but either way it
does seem to slightly contradict the
desire to avoid AI accelerationism next
there was a footnote that restated a
very bold pledge which was that if
another company was approaching AGI
before we did open AI the open AI would
commit to stop competing with and start
assisting that project and that the
trigger for this would occur when there
was a better than even chance of success
in the next two years now Sam Altman and
openai have defined AGI as AI systems
that are generally smarter than humans
so that either means that they think
we're more than two years away from that
or that they have dropped everything and
are working with another company
although I think we'd all have heard
about that or third that the definition
is so vague that it's quite
non-committal please do let me know your
thoughts in the comments next Insight is
the openai employed super forecasters to
help them predict what would happen when
they deployed gpt4 in this extract it
just talks about expert forecasters but
when you go into the appendices you find
out that they're talking about super
forecasters who are these guys
essentially they're people who have
proven that they can forecast the future
pretty well or at least 30 percent
better than intelligence analysts openai
wanted to know what these guys thought
would happen when they deployed the
model and hear their recommendations
about avoiding risks interestingly these
forecasters predicted several things
would reduce acceleration including
delaying the deployment of gpt4 by a
further six months that would have taken
us almost to Autumn of this year now
clearly open AI didn't take up that
advice perhaps due to the pressure from
Microsoft we don't know there were quite
a few benchmarks released in the
technical report there's another one I
want to highlight today I looked through
all of these benchmarks but it was hella
swag that I wanted to focus on first of
all because it's interesting and second
of all because of the gap between gpt4
and the previous state of the art the
headline is this GPT 4 in some
estimations has reached human levels of
common sense now I know that's not as
dramatic as passing the bar exam but
it's nevertheless a milestone for
Humanity how is common sense tested and
how do I know that it's comparable to
Human Performance well I dug into the
literature and found the questions and
examples myself feel free to pause and
read through these examples yourself but
essentially it's testing what is the
most likely thing to occur what's the
most common sense thing to occur but I
want to draw your attention to this
sentence it said though these questions
are trivial for humans with 90 25
accuracy state-of-the-art models
struggle with less than 48 accuracy GPT
4 was 95.3 accurate remember but let's
find the exact number for humans further
on in this paper and here it is overall
95.6 or 95.7 almost exactly the same as
gpc4 the next Insight is about timelines
remember they had this model available
in August of last year that's gpt4 being
completed quite a few months before they
release chat gbt which was based on gpt3
so what explains the long Gap they spent
eight months on Safety Research risk
assessment and iteration I talk about
this in my gpt5 video but let me restate
they had gpt4 available before they
released chat DBT which was based on GPT
3. this made me reflect on the timelines
for Gypsy 5. the time taken to actually
train GPT 5 probably won't be that long
it's already pretty clear that they're
training it on nvidia's h100 tensor core
gpus and look at how much faster they
are for this 400 billion parameter model
it would only take 20 hours to train
with 8 000 h100s versus seven days with
a100 gpus but what am I trying to say
I'm saying that GPT 5 may already be
done but that what will follow is months
and months possibly a year or more of
Safety Research and risk assessment by
the way 400 billion parameters sounds
about right for gpt5 perhaps trained on
four to five trillion tokens again check
out my gbt5 video next they admit that
there's a double-edged sword with the
economic impact of gpc4 they say it may
lead to the automation the full
automation of certain jobs and they talk
about how it's going to impact even
professions like the legal profession
but they also mention and back up with
research the insane productivity gains
in the meanwhile I read through each of
the studies they linked to and some of
them are fascinating one of the studies
includes an experiment where they got
together a bunch of marketers grant
writers Consultants data analysts human
resource professionals and managers they
gave them a bunch of realistic tasks and
split them into a group that could use
chat DBT and a group that couldn't and
then they got a bunch of experienced
professionals who didn't know which
group was which and they assessed the
outputs the results were these using
Chach BT and remember that's not gpt4
the time taken to do a task dropped
almost in half and the rated performance
did increase significantly this is gonna
be huge news for the economy a related
study released in February was using
GitHub copilot which again isn't the
latest technology and found that
programmers using it completed tasks 56
faster than the control group this
brought to mind a chart I had seen from
The Arc investment Management Group
predicting a 10-fold increase in coding
productivity by 2030 and that brings me
back to the technical report which talks
about how gpt4 might increase inequality
that would be my broad prediction too
that some people will use this
technology to be insanely productive
things done 10 times faster or 10 times
as many things being done but depending
on the size of the economy and how it
grows it could also mean a decline of
wages given the competitive cost of the
model a simple way of putting it is that
if gpt4 can do half your job you can get
twice as much done using it the
productivity gains will be amazing when
it can do 90 of your job you can get 10
times as much done but there might come
a slight problem when it can do a
hundred percent or more of your job and
it is honestly impossible to put a
timeline on that and of course it will
depend on the industry and the job there
was one more thing that I found
fascinating from the Rapport they admit
that they're now using an approach
similar to anthropics it's called
constitutional AI their term is a
rule-based reward model and it works
like this you give the model in this
case GT4 a set of principles to follow
and then you get the model to provide
itself a reward if it follows those
principles it's a smart attempt to
harness the power of AI and make it work
towards human principles openai have not
released the Constitution they're basing
the reward model off they're not telling
us the principles but buried deep in the
appendix was a link to anthropics
principles you can read through them
here or in the link in the description
but I find them interestingly both
positive also subjective one of the
principles is don't respond in a way
that is too preachy please respond in a
socially acceptable Manner and I think
the most interesting principle comes
later on down here choose the response
that's sounds most similar to what a
peaceful ethical and wise person like
MLK or Mahatma Gandhi might say and my
point isn't to praise or criticize any
of these principles but as AI takes over
the world and as these companies write
constitutions that may well end up being
as important as say the American
Constitution I think a little bit of
transparency about what that
Constitution is what those principles
are would surely be helpful if you agree
let me know in the comments and of
course please do leave a like if you've
learned anything from this video I know
that these guys anthropic have released
their Claude plus model and I'll be
comparing that to gpt4 imminently have a
wonderful day